est ouverte le compte-rendu analytique
de la précédente séance a été distribuée
il n'y a pas d'observation
le procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous prie d'excuser le président du
Sénat en déplacement à Colombelles les
deux églises
je vous rappelle
je vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmis en direct sur Public Sénat et
sur notre site internet
au nom du bureau du sénage appellent
chacun de vous mes chers collègues à
observer au cours de nos agents l'une
des valeurs essentielles du Sénat le
respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
uns et des autres ou de celui du temps
de parole
la parole est à Madame Christine Labarde
pour le groupe républicain
madame la Première ministre cette
question vous adressée car elle concerne
plusieurs membres de votre gouvernement
et je vois qui a été choisi pour me
répondre quelqu'un qui n'a pas assisté
au débat dont il va être question un de
nos illustres prédécesseurs sur ses
bancs a dit que la forme c'est le fond
qui remonte à la surface alors ma
question va être en deux temps tout
d'abord la forme comment pouvez-vous
oser redéposer par l'intermédiaire d'un
49,3 une disposition qui a été rejetée
par les deux assemblées une première
fois à l'Assemblée nationale une
deuxième fois au Sénat et cette
disposition d'ailleurs a été déposée en
catimini car elle ne figurait pas dans
les amendements retenus dans la première
version du texte et on l'a vu arriver
dans le texte consolidé envoyé le jeudi
matin aux assemblées je parle là des
contrats de confiance au contrat de
Cahors et donc j'en arrive maintenant à
ma question sur le fond madame la
Première ministre cette disposition
vatale être remise une fois que le Sénat
leur a supprimé lors de l'étude de la du
PLF pour 2023 dont le 49.3 qui sera de
nouveau déposer à l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'avare de quoi s'agit-il je
pense que vous faites référence à
l'article 23
et à un processus législatif que je
souhaite reprendre quelques instants
maman de
du début de ce quinquennat la première
ministre a souhaité que la nature des
relations nous puissions engager avec
les associations d'élus change de nature
et ça a donné lieu à une rédaction
initiale celle effectivement d'un
dispositif qui tournait le dos contrat
de Cahors qui supposait des engagements
individuels en préfecture avec des
trajectoires assorties de sanctions qui
étaient très automatisées pour arriver
un schéma passe à lui et par toutes les
associations des lieux mais par
certaines d'entre elles comme étant une
évolution du dispositif de dialogue je
pense en particulier à intercommunalité
de France et la DCS et la DF pardon qui
repose sur l'idée d'arrêter un objectif
global de dépenses publiques dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques et qu'à l'issue des
comptes administratifs 2023 par strat on
regarde où on en est et qu'on puisse
ensuite seulement s'il y a des
dépassements regardez à l'intérieur de
la strate les collectivités qui
dépassent
le problème c'est que ce dispositif dont
on a besoin pour crédibiliser la
trajectoire des finances publiques de la
France a été écarté dans le cadre de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques
il a été décidé dans le cadre du PLF de
réintroduire les articles dont nous
avions besoin pour crédibiliser cette
trajectoire des finances publiques et
très concrètement c'est une façon aussi
de reprovoquer le dialogue on peut pas
écarter d'un revers de main
j'ose
espérer
j'ose espérer
que ça n'est pas la nature de la
relation que vous aurez quand on va
entrer dans le détail de ces articles le
gouvernement est prêt sur ce sujet à
discuter mais il considère que la voix
d'un compromis à la fois sur les
finances des collectivités sur les
finances de l'état nécessite précisément
un travail de co-construction et le
balayer d'un revers de main ne peut pas
être une attitude responsable merci
Monsieur le Ministre madame Lavarde
alors juste je voudrais revenir sur
cette histoire de crédibiliser la
trajectoire des finances publiques pour
vous dire que les a pull c'est 9% de la
dette publique les a pull sont en
excédent les a pulls sont la période
2018-2021 on fait des économies de 11
milliards par rapport aux temps
anciennes alors même que les contrats de
Cahors avaient été à journée alors je
suis désolé mais cette crédibilité quand
je cite le ministrateur qui nous dit si
on veut contenir l'évolution de la
dépense publique des collectivités
territorales il faut prévoir un
mécanisme d'encadrement c'est une
question de crédibilité mais alors
pourquoi appelez-vous ça contrat de
confiance et Monsieur le Ministre BECHU
je suis désolé mais je vais vous citer
au mois de juin sur Public Sénat vous
indiquez il est certain qu'on ne
repartira pas sur les bases d'un contrat
de Cahors qui consisterait à dire qu'il
y a un pourcentage d'inflation à ne pas
dépasser vous avez récidivé début
juillet au moment de l'inauguration de
Landru vous avez dit il va de soi que
l'idée de penser que l'on va faire dans
ce qu'un canal la même chose que ce que
l'on a fait dans le quinquennat
précédent avec mon contrat de cas des
objectifs n'existe pas excusez-moi mais
là c'est exactement la même chose qu'on
nous propose et c'était même pire dans
la version initiale puisque vous
encadriez le fonctionnement et vous
venez reprendre
la dotation de l'État pour
l'investissement des collectivités donc
vous mettiez même à Malte le financement
de la transition
[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole est maintenant au président
Jean-François Longeot pour le groupe
Union centriste merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du Travail
et la COP 27 c'est ouverte dimanche
dernier à Charm el-cheik il s'agit d'un
rendez-vous déterminant pour l'avenir de
la planète nous ne pouvons que saluer
les engagements pris par l'Europe et la
France pour parvenir à la neutralité
carbone en 2050 atteindre cet objectif
va nécessiter
des compétences tel est l'objectif de ma
question celle des ressources humaines
et de la transition si nous ne prenons
pas assez au sérieux l'enjeu de la
formation la transition écologique
pourrait demain se heurter à une pénurie
de savoir-faire dans notre pays en ce
moment même des soudeurs américains
réparent les défauts de corrosion sous
contrainte de notre parc nucléaire car
nous n'avons pas assez de ressources
humaines pour y parvenir seul dans des
délais resserrés actuels parmi les
problématiques les plus parlantes au
sujet de la pénurie de compétences on
sait que le secteur des transports est
l'un des gros émetteurs de gaz à effet
de serre le ferroviaire va avoir un rôle
clé dans le verdissement de ces secteurs
or une étude prospective menée par
l'Observatoire des métiers de la
métallurgie a récemment démontré que
d'ici à 2030 le besoin en ingénieur
ferroviaire serait de près de 14000
ingénieurs nécessitant plus de 7900
nouveaux recrutements en tenant compte
des départs à la retraite
ce qui signifie que devrait sortir des
formations supérieures spécialisées dans
le ferroviaire environ 790 ingénieurs
par an alors ils n'en sort aujourd'hui
que 250 la question étant l'occurrence
quantitative mais elle est aussi
qualitative il faut former à la
décarbonation c'est particulièrement en
vrai dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables du nucléaire ou encore de
l'agriculture telle était d'ailleurs le
message de l'appel des étudiants de
l'AgroParisTech il déplorait ne pas être
formé à la gros écologie monsieur le
ministre alors de la COP 27 notre
système de formation initiale et
continue a-t-il bien pris en compte
l'enjeu de la transition
environnementale si oui comment merci
merci chers collègues la parole et à
Monsieur Olivier dussoque ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le Président Longeot
d'abord merci de rappeler par votre
question l'importance des transitions
l'importance des travaux menait leur de
la cop27 mais pour vous répondre en deux
points un premier point simplement pour
dire que vous avez 1000 fois raison sur
ce qui concerne la formation initiale et
la nécessité qu'elle soit orientée vers
l'accompagnement des transitions et en
particulier la transition écologique mon
collègue ministre de l'éducation
nationale avec madame la ministre
déléguée en charge de la formation
professionnelle pourrait vous dire tout
ce qui est fait en matière de
réorientation de la formation de
réorientation et de réforme de la loi
professionnelle justement pour avoir des
formations qualifiantes qui permettent
d'aborder l'avenir c'est vrai pour les
études secondaires c'est vrai pour les
études supérieures madame la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur il veille aussi
faire en sorte que notre appareil de
formation initiale intègre pleinement
les besoins de formation que vous avez
évoqué mais au-delà de la formation
initiale nous devons aussi penser
des transitions pour l'ensemble des
entreprises et l'ensemble des salariés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes aussi extrêmement attentifs à ce
que les entreprises puissent accompagner
la transition en leur sang vous avez
évoqué le secteur du nucléaire vous avez
évoqué l'agriculture vous allez évoquer
le secteur de l'hydrogène et des
transports le secteur de l'automobile
aussi est particulièrement concerné et
nous devons faire en sorte par la
formation continue par les dispositifs
de transition de transition collective
par les dispositifs de formation des
salariés d'accompagner cette transition
pour que celles et ceux qui ont été
formés sur des techniques qui étaient
des techniques d'excellence il y a 10
ans 15 ans 20 ans puisse être à nouveau
formé monté pouvoir monter en
qualification et accompagner ces
transition dans le cadre de la loi de
finance pour 2023 vous aurez l'occasion
de le constater dans les prochains jours
plus de 350 millions d'euros ont été
prévus pour réabonder le Front national
Pôle emploi sur son volet formation le
FNA formation pour financer aussi les
dispositifs de transition collective et
permettre dans le cas du dialogue social
que les branches professionnelles se
saisissent de ce besoin de reclassement
de formation et d'apport de nouvelles
qualifications de nouvelles compétences
à leurs salariés et ainsi répondre aux
enjeux de transition que vous avez
rappelé
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Gérard
laelec pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
Transports
dans le contexte où se réunit la cop27
il est bon de rappeler que les
transports représentent un tiers de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mais pas en raison des politiques
publiques mais plutôt en raison de ce
que nous font pas de nos politiques
publiques tout le monde s'accorde pour
reconnaître que pour changer de cap
atteindre la neutralité carbone d'ici
2050 et doubler la part du ferroviaire
d'ici 2030 ce n'est pas de mesurer dont
nous avons besoin mais au contraire
d'une grande ambition publique il nous
faut tout à la fois développer le frais
de ferroviaire assurer la remise à
niveau de notre réseau par un tout autre
contrat de performance ou encore
pourquoi pas développer les trains de
nuit donc la marge de progression est
gigantesque comme la rappeler et nous on
le rappelle constamment les mouvements
des usagers la désertion de nos
territoires il est difficultés de
recrutement et précisément s'il est un
thème sur lequel on peut agir c'est bien
sur le thème des transports une majorité
politique existe pour dégager des moyens
supplémentaires à la fois au Sénat comme
un test des divers rapport adopté ici
mais aussi à l'Assemblée nationale ou un
amendement au budget proposant 3
milliards d'euros supplémentaires pour
le ferroviaire a été adopté disons-le
avec des voix de gauche et des voies de
droite le gouvernement est-il prêt à
s'emparer de cette situation inédite
d'une majorité politique possible pour
dégager des moyens afin de donner un
nouvel élan au transport ferroviaire
merci
merci la parole
à monsieur le ministre des Transports
monsieur Clément bonne
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur lalek vous avez raison
d'insister sur cette priorité je crois
vous l'avez exprimé dans le temps même
de votre question elle est largement
partagée il y a un consensus à la fois
pour rappeler les chiffres que vous avez
indiqué les transports pardon c'est 30 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
notre consommation énergétique et donc
nous devons lui donner une priorité très
forte notamment dans le transport
ferroviaire et dans le report d'autres
modes de transport vers le ferroviaire
le budget qui sera soumis à votre débat
dans quelques jours porte un effort
extrêmement important en faveur des
transports et notamment les transports
publics je tiens à le redire parce que
c'est parfois un peu oubli dans notre
débat quand nous avons plus de la moitié
de l'effort de l'État au total 12
milliards d'euros 6,6 pour le transport
ferroviaire qui est consacré précisément
au train et aux transports publics je ne
crois je crois que ce ne sont pas
exactement ni des mesurettes ni des
cacahuètes budgétaires quand nous avons
plus de 85% du programme budgétaire des
transports qui sont consacrés pour la
première fois au transport ferroviaire
je crois que nous sommes aussi dans une
action importante vous avez évoqué un
certain nombre le domaine plus précis je
pense aux fraises nous avons un plan
d'un milliard d'euros sur 6 ans qui est
consacré au fret les petites lignes qui
vous sont chères et qui sont si
importantes c'est pour la première fois
le premier ministre Jean Castex avait
initié d'ailleurs ce mouvement ce sont
les protocoles pour préaler 6 milliards
d'euros qui sont aujourd'hui signés avec
les régions pour investir sur plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres de lignes près de
6000 d'ores et déjà devons-nous
prolonger amplifier cet effort ensemble
oui c'est exactement la démarche
transpartizane que vous avez décrite qui
allait occasion de se déployer dans le
cadre du comité du Conseil par une
orientation les infrastructures laquelle
participent plusieurs membres du Sénat
comme plusieurs membres de l'Assemblée
nationale toute sensibilité confondues
nous aurons ces travaux d'ici la fin de
l'année et sur cette base nous pourrons
aussi définir une programmation des
moyens et des priorités très claires
pour le ferroviaire en particulier
j'insiste sur un point j'insiste sur un
point qui est essentiel c'est que le
réseau ferroviaire doit être absolument
prioritaire dans nos choix budgétaire et
c'est en plus la responsabilité de
l'État du niveau national que d'investir
encore davantage dans ce réseau je veux
dire que nous avons quasiment le doublé
les crédits qui consacrer ces cinq
dernières années donc nous avons engagé
cette démarche nous irons plus loin et
nous le ferons ensemble merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur Laennec merci
monsieur le ministre en tout cas il ne
faudrait pas que vous considériez qu'il
n'y a de majorité politique que lorsque
c'est le gouvernement qui décide vous
avez la chance de disposer de
dispositions parlementaires saisissons
je pense l'occasion pour avancer
ensemble
merci chers collègues la parole au
président Alain Richard pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie les
entreprises industrielles de quelques
secteurs fortement utilisateurs
d'énergie concentrent une part
importante des émissions gaz à effet de
serre
celle qui opère en France ne font pas
exception mais nous savons tous que les
décennies passées ont vu certaines
industries disparaitrent et ce n'est
évidemment pas de ce côté-là qu'il a
solution
pour l'avenir la réduction efficace de
nos émissions ne peut pas se traduire
par une nouvelle désindustrialisation et
par un gonflement de nos importations
les responsables de ces entreprises ont
pour beaucoup d'entre eux progressé dans
leur transformation et commencer à
obtenir des résultats le rythme de
baisse les émissions des industriels
français se comparent honorablement à
celui de leur concurrents de l'Union
européenne et des grands pays développés
mais il faut aller plus vite le
président de la République a organisé
une réflexion partagée avec ses
dirigeants pour définir ensemble le
meilleur programme d'action le thème
était comment répondre à l'urgence
climatique et soutenir des industries
modernisées créatives et compétitive
pour produire de la richesse et
développer de l'emploi qualifiée en
France Monsieur le Ministre quelles sont
les grands engagements que le
gouvernement veut obtenir de nos
partenaires industriels et quels sont
les grands axes du programme de soutien
que vous pourrez présenter prochainement
pour relever ce défi
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie
merci et monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Alain Richard je vais vous
raconter
une histoire
pas
pas une histoire à dormir debout
une histoire à rêver de vous
c'est celle du site de Solvay que nous
avons visité ce matin avec le ministre
de l'Industrie Roland Lescure un site
qui a un siècle d'histoire industrielle
derrière lui un site qui produit des
produits chimiques du carbonate de soude
du bicarbonate de soude avec comme
énergie du charbon importé de Russie
ainsi donc émet beaucoup de CO2 qui a
des problèmes de compétitivité et qui
aujourd'hui ne répond plus au standards
les plus innovants et à nos exigences
environnementales ce site est en train
d'opérer une révolution climatique et
industrielle il va transformer son
énergie charbon en utilisant les déchets
recyclables de tout le bassin tout le
bassin géographique pour réduire son
empreinte carbone améliorer sa
compétitivité et ouvrir un nouveau
siècle d'histoire industriel pour le
site de Solvay et bien je veux rendre
hommage aux ouvriers aux ingénieurs au
techniciens aux entrepreneurs à se lever
qui opère cette révolution industrielle
et environnementale cette décarbonation
cette histoire a rêvé debout elle doit
être l'histoire de tous les grands sites
industriels français et notamment des 56
industriels que le Président de la
République a choisi auquel nous allons
apporter 5 milliards d'euros d'aide
immédiatement et 5 milliards d'euros
d'aide complémentaires si jamais nous
suivent dans cet objectif de
décarbonation pour que nous ayons demain
l'industrie mondiale la plus décarbonée
de la planète voilà une grande ambition
pour la France et voilà l'objectif que
nous nous sommes fixés avec le président
de la République et pour tenir cet
objectif non seulement nous allons
accompagner chacun de ces 56 mais nous
en avons complété de deux décisions la
première c'est évidemment accompagner
toutes ces entreprises dans les mois qui
viennent pour faire face à l'explosion
leur facture d'énergie et pour qu'elle
puisse accomplir cette transition en
ayant le soutien de l'État
l'accompagnement de l'État et la
deuxième décision c'est accélérer la
mise en place d'une max carbone aux
frontières parce que la décarbonation de
notre industrie qui construira l'avenir
industriel français doit se faire aussi
sur la base d'une équité de concurrence
en évitant d'importer des produits qui
eux continuent à polluer et qui viennent
du dehors des frontières de l'Europe
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
monsieur
le Président pas de réplique
bien je vais passer maintenant la parole
à notre collègue Emilienne Poumirol pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur mise la santé et de
la prévention soit des programmes et
faute de lit transfert hors région de
certains patients enfants hospitalisé
dans des services adultes les services
de pédiatrie sont saturés douleurs cris
de détresse il y a quelques jours et la
situation tendue en pédiatrie n'est que
l'arbre qui cache la forêt car c'est
tout l'hôpital public qui est en voie
d'effondrement le vrai problème est
structurel les conditions de travail
amènent les personnels à quitter
l'hôpital et des services y compris aux
urgences doivent être fermées
face à cette situation vous avez annoncé
un plan pour soutenir les services en
tension d'hôpital de 150 millions
d'euros puis de 400 millions d'euros et
enfin hier au détour du débat sur le
PLFSS de 556 millions d'euros au total
et ce sans aucune nouvelle recette ces
enveloppes successives bien que
bienvenue sont l'illustration de votre
pilotage à la petite semaine malgré
votre communication lambda met deux fois
inférieur à l'inflation et de fait le
gouvernement réduit les moyens du
système de soins et l'hôpital public
année la première victime alors monsieur
le ministre a quand une réponse pérenne
et d'envergure pour l'hôpital public
merci chers collègues la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé de la
prévention Monsieur François Braun
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice pomirol vous imaginez bien et
vous le savez je suis de très près la
situation des services de pédiatrie plus
généralement la situation également de
notre hôpital le public et de ses
difficultés
je peux vous assurer que l'ensemble des
moyens disponibles sont mobilisés pour
faire face à cette nouvelle crise et à
cette épidémie de bronchiolite santé
publique France d'ailleurs ce matin nous
indiquait que c'est une épidémie qui
dépasse les pics épidémiques que nous
avons connues depuis plus de 10 ans
d'ailleurs pour accompagner cette cette
information j'ai décidé ce matin en
complément de tout ce qui était déjà
mobilisé de déclencher le plan hors-sant
spécifique à cette épidémie pour
renforcer encore les moyens des ARS et
permettre que l'ensemble de l'hôpital
puisse se concentrer sur ce problème
particulièrement aigu aujourd'hui
des mesures d'urgence ont été prises et
le gouvernement et je remercie le Sénat
à amené effectivement des moyens
financiers supplémentaires pour faire
face à ces difficultés mais je vous
rejoins lorsque vous dites que le
problème est plus structurel au sein de
notre hôpital public et de notre système
de santé et le ministère de la Santé de
la prévention ne doit pas et ne sera pas
uniquement un ministère de crise mais un
ministère chargé de refonder notre
système de santé dans son ensemble c'est
d'ailleurs tout l'enjeu du Conseil
national de la refondation en santé qui
a voulu le président de la République
j'ai commencé à rencontrer depuis une
semaine l'ensemble des professionnels
bien sûr de la pédiatrie mais l'ensemble
des professionnels de l'hôpital
également en ce qui concerne plus
spécifiquement la pédiatrie nous
travaillons aux Assises de la pédiatrie
et de la santé de l'enfant puisque tout
le chant de la santé de l'enfant mérite
d'être réformé nous aboutirons au
printemps avec une feuille de route pour
les années à venir sur l'ensemble de la
santé de l'enfant dans les mêmes dates
nous aurons les résultats des différents
CNR territoriaux et nationaux sur la
santé pour la refondation de notre
système de santé pour qu'il soit basé
non plus sur l'offre de soins mais bien
sur la réponse aux besoins de santé de
la population française je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues allez-y
monsieur le ministre ne veut pas se
cacher derrière l'épidémie de
bronchiolite pour parler des problèmes
actuels vous avez fait des choix et ses
choix il faut maintenant les assumer
vous avez décidé de faire porter les
17,7 milliards d'euros de la dette covid
sur la sécurité sociale créant cette
année son déficit vous avez décidé
d'exonération de cotisations qui sont
passées en 5 ans de 39 à 71 milliards
mais vous refusez dans le même temps
toutes les propositions que nous avons
pu vous faire pour trouver de nouvelles
recettes c'est donc que vous faites le
choix délibéré du déficit pour la
sécurité sociale et ce peut-être ou sans
doute au profit du système privé but
lucratif alors monsieur le ministre nous
sommes à croiser des chemins soit vous
décidez d'abandonner l'hôpital public
soit vous engagez enfin cette réforme
structurelle le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains de son côté
éclaire et réclame une réforme urgente
et pérenne de l'encontre du ratio
patient personnel soignant sur tous les
territoires
merci chers collègues
et maintenant la parole est notre
collègue Ghislaine Pantel pour le groupe
du Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre et mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
vous êtes interpellé à intervalles
réguliers dans cette émission sur les
ressources dont dispose des
collectivités territoriales pour
alimenter leur budget et assurer le bon
fonctionnement des services publics
locaux après la suppression progressive
de la taxe d'habitation au cours du
premier mandat d'Emmanuel Macron l'année
2023 doit être marquée par une nouvelle
étape dans la transformation de la
fiscalité locale avec la suppression de
la cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises la CVAE doit donc être
supprimé après avoir vu son taux divisé
par deux en 2021 naturellement des
mécanismes de compensation voient
systématiquement le jour avec plus ou
moins de réactivité comme le transfert
de la part départementale de la taxe
foncière sur les propriétés bâties aux
communes ainsi que l'ajout d'un
coefficient correcteur dans les cas où
le transfert ne suffit pas
or plusieurs
arguments viennent se percuter avec ce
système de suppression compensation si
l'intention de ce gouvernement est
d'enclencher une vraie décentralisation
la disparition de taxes doit pas avoir
pour effet de restreindre les ressources
fiscales des collectivités territoriales
au point d'entraver leur libre
administration et leur développement
le contexte inflationniste nous prouve
que les dotations de l'État qui par
définition ne sont pas dynamiques ne
peuvent se satisfaire les besoins en
fonctionnement et investissement des
collectivités un exemple la commune de
montbet dans Lozère perçoit une DGF de
25000 euros alors que le fonctionnement
de l'école lui coûte 20.000 euros par an
c'est Costa sont faits depuis bien
longtemps il est maintenant nécessaire
de réinventer à la fois les concours
financiers de l'État et la fiscalité
locale pour que les communes et
collectivités rurales puissent se
développer accueillir de nouvelles
populations et faciliter la création
d'entreprise en somme le gouvernement
a-t-il l'intention d'impulser une
réflexion globale pour un système plus
équilibré de ressources pour les
collectivités et notamment les plus
rurales je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame
Caroline cailleux ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Pantel vous m'interrogez sur
l'évolution des ressources des
collectivités locales face au
suppressions des impôts locaux et au
montant de la DGF des petites communes
je voudrais tout d'abord faire un rappel
à savoir que les suppressions d'impôts
sont une bonne chose pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français car elles servent à
leur augmenter et d'autre part elles
permettent d'améliorer la compétitivité
des entreprises du côté des
collectivités locales pour la taxe
d'habitation comme pour la CVAE il y a
des compensations à l'Europe qui sont
prévues elles seront dynamiques en clair
pour revenir sur la CVAE
à la demande des associations d'élus
nous leur avons consacré une part de TVA
notamment vous le voyez la volonté du
gouvernement c'est bien de préserver
l'autonomie des collectivités et j'y
suis moi-même personnellement attaché en
ce qui concerne la dotation globale de
fonctionnement après la forte baisse ou
le mandat de François Hollande la DGF a
été stabilisée à partir de 2018 avec le
PLF 2023 ce sont 320 millions d'euros
qui sont rajoutés pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans dont 200 millions d'euros
de hausse pour la dotation de solidarité
rurale dont bénéficieront les communes
de Lozère c'est un changement important
demandé par de nombreux élus locaux et
de parlementaires depuis de nombreuses
années alors faut-il aller encore plus
loin je sais que la Cour des comptes a
proposé au Sénat une réflexion sont très
ambitieuses et pour ce sujet comme pour
tout ce qui concerne nos collectivités
je reste évidemment à l'écoute de la
chambre des territoires et de vos
propositions avant de conclure je
voudrais rappeler néanmoins que au-delà
des concours financiers de l'État le
gouvernement a mis en place une
politique ambitieuse pour accompagner et
soutenir nos territoires ruraux je pense
à l'agenda rural et qui en est parfaite
exemple tout comme le programme petite
ville de demain
[Musique]
merci
mais le respect du temps de parole fait
partie de notre règle du jeu commune
la parole à notre collègue Monique de
Marco pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
parlant festival
j'avoue être un peu perdu je ne sais
plus si je dois m'adresser au ministre
de l'intérieur ou à vous madame la
ministre de la Culture pourquoi le 25
octobre le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Darmanin a présenté le
dispositif de sécurité des Jeux
Olympiques et paralympique de 2024 près
de 45000 policiers gendarmes seraient
mobilisés de juillet à septembre
face à l'ampleur de ce dispositif il a
évoqué je cite la possible annulation le
report de tous les événements en France
qui demandent des unités de force mobile
à l'heure des programmations des
organisateurs de festivals les syndicats
les centaines de milliers de
travailleurs du secteur et les millions
de spectateurs s'inquiètent faute de
services de sécurité suffisant les
festivals seront-ils sacrifiés pour les
Jeux Olympiques
les festivals sont l'image de la France
et de son exception culturelle il
garantissent une offre culturelle
diversifiée dans l'ensemble du
territoire en attirant des millions de
personnes leur retombées financière sont
également conséquentes par exemple les
francophonies de La Rochelle génèrent 11
millions d'euros le Festival d'Avignon
50 millions d'euros et les fêtes de
Bayonne attirent chaque année un million
de personnes si l'activité financière
festivalière est annulé qui assurera les
conséquences financières
l'annulation ou le report serait
catastrophique pour un secteur qui peine
à se remettre de la pandémie la culture
ne doit pas être une nouvelle fois la
variable d'ajustement de décision de
nationale
vous avez tenu une réunion avec les
acteurs de la filière le 2 novembre qui
n'a pas permis de répondre à leurs
inquiétudes vous n'avez apporté ni
solution ni réponse il ne suffit pas
madame la ministre de dire que vous êtes
consciente des enjeux nous voulons
savoir qui sera concerné quand comment
et dans quelle mesure comme tous les
acteurs du spectacle vivant et de la
musique nous attendons des réponses
claires et des engagements je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Madame drimable ministre de la
Culture
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de Marco vous avez raison de
dire que la France est une terre de
festivals que c'est une partie
importante de l'ADN culturel de la
France notamment l'été et vous avez
raison de mentionner toutes les
retombées économiques pour les
territoires qui sont majeurs mais nous
savons aussi que l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques c'est un moment exceptionnel
hors norme c'est une fois par siècle ça
va être un grand moment festif et
populaire qui nécessite une organisation
hors norme évidemment une sécurisation
particulièrement renforcée or les
festivals aussi ont besoin d'être
sécurisés les festivals mobilisent pour
les très très grands festivals qui
mobilisent des dizaines de milliers de
personnes des unités de force mobile
donc le travail que nous sommes en train
de faire avec Gérald Darmanin et Amélie
oudea Castéra c'est ce travail fin au
cas par cas des situations les plus
impactées pour chercher les solutions
pour voir comment concilier le mieux
possible cette vitalité naturel des
festivals et les nécessités de
sécurisation pour eux comme pour les
Jeux olympiques mais il y a aussi
l'enjeu des moyens techniques des
personnels des tensions sur les
bénévoles sur les transports des
spectateurs c'est un ensemble de
paramètres en réalité qui impactent les
festivals et qui nécessitent un travail
au cas par cas face par phase avec les
professionnels vous l'avez dit je les ai
reçus assez longuement je poursuis le
travail en bilatérale si je puis dire
avec chacun d'entre eux et avec leurs
syndicats leurs organisations
professionnelles nous sommes en train
dans les semaines qui viennent nous
verrons se dessiner certaines solutions
et je pourrais vous en faire part nous
sommes pleinement conscients de cette
nécessité de concilier la force des Jeux
Olympiques et la force des festivals
je vous remercie merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Pierre-Jean verzelen pour le
groupe Les Indépendants
que se passe-t-il à la SNCF que va faire
la SNCF
nous savons bien que vous n'êtes pas de
président de cette entreprise publique
mais enfin l'État en est l'actionnaire
unique
en général 5% des trains annulés c'est
ce qu'on appelle un trafic normal à la
SNCF mais nous constatons tous que
depuis quelques semaines et de quelques
mois la situation se dégrade je vais
prendre l'exemple d'une région que je
connais bien celle des Hauts de France
en plus des retard depuis le mois
d'avril c'est près d'un train sur 10 en
moyenne et chaque jour qui est annulé ce
qui crée un climat de tension et
d'anxiété pour les usagers et évidemment
et notamment ceux qui travaillent la
raison principale qui est invoquée c'est
le manque de personnel on peut aussi et
notre collègue fait pointer le
sous-investissement chronique dans le
réseau secondaire depuis 30 ans
ce manque d'anticipation de la part de
dirigeants d'un grand groupe public
paraît aberrant comment en sommes-nous
arrivés là et comment la situation va se
rétablir
monsieur le ministre la SNCF prend de
plein fouet la hausse des prix de
l'électricité quid du bouclier tarifaire
pour protéger les voyageurs de la hausse
du prix des billets
déjà que nous savons que le train n'est
pas forcément plus attractif que la
voiture ou l'avion au moment où la
France prend des engagements à la cop27
on ne peut pas se satisfaire que le
moyen de transport le plus écolo en CO2
soit financièrement le moins intéressant
j'ajoute que les régions en charge des
TER sont censés je dis bien censés avoir
un dialogue quotidien avec la SNCF elles
sont confrontées à un manque de
transparence de la part de l'entreprise
et aussi de ce qu'on peut appeler le
Triangle des Bermudes de la SNCF c'est à
dire une organisation enfin une
désorganisation plutôt où il y a
tellement d'interlocuteurs on ne sait
plus qui fait quoi on ne sait plus qui
vous répond et personne ne sait vous
dire oui ou non monsieur le ministre
comment retrouver cette relation de
confiance entre les régions et la SNCF
comment rétablir l'offre de train et
comment la SNCF va répercuter ou pas la
hausse du coût de l'énergie sur le prix
des billets merci
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
Clément bonne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vergelen vous avez raison je
n'ai pas l'habitude de fuir mes
responsabilités nous parlons d'un grand
service public qui lui entreprise
entièrement public et donc cela ne peut
pas rester sans réponse ou faire face à
un quelconque désintérêt de la part de
l'État c'est la raison pour laquelle je
l'ai dit la situation est haut de France
est inacceptable et nous avons eu un
entretien puisque les TER sont
effectivement la charge des régions avec
le président Xavier Bertrand je me suis
rendu à l'île dès lundi je me suis sur
entretenu hier avec le président farando
une nouvelle fois il y a un effort
exceptionnel de formation qui est fait
pour compenser ce que vous avez décrit
c'est-à-dire une pénurie de conducteurs
qui malheureusement parce que cela fait
partie des métiers en tension ne
concerne pas que la région des Hauts de
France mais concerne très fortement très
douloureusement les usagers des Hauts de
France aujourd'hui il y a un plan qui a
été tout à fait exceptionnel qui a été
mise en place ces derniers mois qui
prévoit en 2022 2023 le recrutement
inédit de 440 collaborateurs TER en haut
de France mais j'ai demandé aux prises
en pharaon de ouf face à la gravité de
la situation un exceptionnel d'urgence
et d'accélération de ces recrutements
par tous les moyens possibles qui sera
présenté par l'entreprise dans les
prochains jours en lien avec la région
car cette situation ne peut rester sans
réponse je l'ai dit très honnêtement une
situation de cette nature ne se règle
pas en quelques jours elle ne se résout
pas totalement quelques semaines mais
nous devons montrer les améliorations
visibles sérieuses dans les toutes
prochaines semaines pour les usagers
vous avez parlé aussi de la question
tarifaire cela doit mérite mérite pardon
quelques précisions d'abord les tarifs
qui sont justement ceux du TER et de
beaucoup de trains des quotidiens ne
relève pas de l'État les tarifs en
revanche qui sont ceux des trains à
grande vitesse ou des trains d'équilibre
du territoire sont de niveau national du
ressort national c'est dans ce contexte
que j'ai demandé pour ces trains à la
SNCF te mettre en place un bouclier
tarifaire qu'est-ce que cela signifie
concrètement cela signifie que nous
devons d'abord agir pour réduire les
charges de la SNCF c'est ce que fait
l'état par les mesures que nous prenons
sur la maîtrise des coûts de l'énergie
qui a permis de réduire très fortement
le montant qu’évoquait devant le Sénat
le président farondoux près de 2
milliards d'euros nous ne sommes plus du
tout dans ces ordres de grandeur ensuite
d'avoir des hausses qui sont en toute
état de cause inférieure à l'inflation
et troisième point de préserver ceux qui
ont le plus besoin du train les ménages
modestes les utilisateurs réguliers
notamment pour le travail c'est pourquoi
j'ai demandé un effort tout particulier
sur les abonnements et sur les wigos ce
plan sera présenté là aussi dans
quelques jours par la SNCF je vous
remercie si monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Bruno Belin pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues la France est à sec à sec
d'argent à sec do à sec d'électricité à
sec de gaz à sec de nucléaire à sec de
médecins et maintenant à sec de certains
médicaments
spasfon et gaviscon nous cherchons
amoxicilline et paracétamol aussi rare
que le pétrole en cette épidémie de
bronchiolite c'est dramatique ce sont
pourtant des médicaments matures peut
onéreux et essentiel tout au long de
l'année alors ma question monsieur le
ministre de la Santé est aussi simple
qu'elle inquiète les professionnels de
santé et les patients quelle est votre
stratégie pour que la France puisse
retrouver sa souveraineté sur les
produits de santé
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
François braune ministre de la Santé de
la prévention
Michel Président Mesdames et Messieurs
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Bruno
Belin le président de la République a
fixé un cap lors du conseil stratégique
des industries de santé de 2021
réindustrialisé garantir notre capacité
d'approvisionnement et notre
souveraineté tout en maintenant un taux
de croissance de l'industrie du
médicament supérieur à 2%. nous avons
deux enjeux favoriser l'innovation
soutenir l'accès aux médicaments
innovants mais aussi maintenir l'accès à
des médicaments plus anciens mais
particulièrement
utile vous parliez du paracétamol c'est
bien sûr un enjeu majeur de santé
publique à ce titre des obligations ont
été renforcées pour les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur des
obligations au niveau du volume des
stocks des obligations également au
niveau des moyens des dispositifs
d'alerte en cas de crainte de rupture
toutefois et je vous rejoins nous
connaissons en ce moment des tensions
liées à la reprise covid sur certains
médicaments plus que sur certains
médicaments sur certaines formes
médicaments parler de l'amoxicilline en
particulier le sirop amoxicilline est
difficile d'accès alors que les autres
formes d'amoxicilline sont facilement
accessibles vous évoquez la bronchiolite
j'en profite et je suis obligé dans
cette semaine de l'antibio-résistance de
bien préciser que la bronchiolite est
une maladie virale sur laquelle il ne
faut pas donner d'antibiotiques au
risque de développer l'antibiorésistance
je suis bien sûr ces situations en temps
réel avec l'Agence nationale de sécurité
du médicament situation qui sont
complexes et j'ai demandé toute la
transparence aux industriels il est
difficile de faire la part des choses
entre les déficiences de produits actifs
et la efficience justement de capacité
d'emballage que ce soit le verre ou que
ce soit le carton nous avons un plan
comme vous le savez pénurie je ferais
bientôt le point là-dessus en ce qui
concerne le développement d'une filière
française de l'industrie du médicament
voulu là aussi par le Président de la
République je vous rappelle que dans le
cas du plan France 2030 7,5 milliards
d'euros ont été mis dans cette filière à
titre d'exemple et vous parliez du
paracétamol l'année prochaine ouvre en
Isère une usine qui va produire 10 000
tonnes de paracétamol par an pour en
couvrir largement le marché français je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Bolland
je prends acte de votre réponse monsieur
le ministre
et je pense que vous-même et votre
collègue Agnès Firmin malmodo aide de
bonne volonté
mais mais le sirop typhon c'est fini à
vouloir asphyxier le médicament et
surtout son prix Bercy depuis des années
à tuer une industrie nationale
stratégique le coût de la panne du
doliprane est révélateur d'une France
exsangue la réalité c'est Sanofi
incapable de faire avec ça la réalité
c'est des médicaments contingenté tous
les matins la réalité c'est un accès
plus compliqué à la santé c'est
une récession indiscutable de la
puissance santé de la France la
mascarade des masques à illustrer de
façon insoutenable cette impuissance
cette faiblesse
il faut réindustrialiser la France car
aujourd'hui ce sont des médicaments qui
manquent
le combat pour la santé et donc celui
pour la vie passe par là je vous
remercie monsieur le président
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Rémi Cardon
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre les savoirs techniques
Emmanuel sont essentiels à notre
quotidien et à la réussite collective de
notre pays et pourtant lors de sa
présentation sur la réforme de la voix
professionnelle en septembre dernier le
président de la République a fait savoir
qu'il entendait réduire le nombre
d'heures dédiés au savoir fondamentaux
dans les lycées professionnels cela
n'est pas sérieux et pour preuve en
disant presque 1400 heures
d'enseignement ont été supprimés ils
restent aujourd'hui moins de deux heures
de français par semaine pour les Bac Pro
les heures d'enseignement font de en
réalité comme neige au soleil et on
pousse de plus en plus tôt les jeunes
dans les bras du marché du travail au
détriment de leur ouverture culturelle
et de leur émancipation
le manutentionnaire n'aurait pas besoin
de trop d'éloquence pour la base besogne
peu importe si cela le met en difficulté
pour défendre ses droits ou changer sa
carrière un ouvrier n'est pas fait pour
devenir poète ou encore professeur et
puis c'est bien connu s'il veut
s'insurger il aura la grève ou
l'abstention madame la Première ministre
les inégalités commencent dès la
naissance et avec cette réforme vous les
accentuez et même pire vous renoncez à
déjouer les pronostics ce qui est
pourtant au cœur du pacte républicain
alors on ne choisit pas toujours d'où
l'on vient ni le métier que l'on exerce
mais une chose est sûre l'école est
faite pour donner à tous ces élèves une
formation suffisamment qualifiante pour
avoir le choix de partir et de pouvoir
rebondir finalement cette réforme suit
la même logique que votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage à savoir le
travailleur doit se soumettre au marché
du travail et son émancipation ça sera
pour plus tard ma question est assez
simple que comptez-vous faire pour
sécuriser le parcours de vie de notre
jeunesse en lycée professionnel je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues et la parole et
maintenant à madame Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement de la formation
professionnelle merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Cardon au
fond je crois que c'est la première fois
qu'un président de la République porte
aussi fort les valeurs de la voie
professionnelle et le lycée
professionnel au coeur de son engagement
de campagne et de politique publique au
fond tout doit être fait pour faire
réussir la jeunesse et effectivement
alors qu'un tiers des lycéens passe par
la voie professionnelle nous devons
accompagner l'évolution de la voie
professionnelle pour qu'elles mettent en
réussite l'ensemble de ces jeunes vous
l'avez dit Monsieur le sédator nous
avons un défi celui aussi de mettre en
place partout sur tous nos territoires
dans tous les lycées professionnels le
pacte républicain celui de la promesse
que nous devons leur faire qui est celui
de les accompagner bien sûr en tant que
citoyen pour qu'il puisse grandir par
faire effectivement leur éducation et
être demain
les citoyens éclairés qui s'engageront
dans une voie professionnelle et qui
doit aller préparer aussi à une
insertion professionnelle réussie c'est
tout le défi finalement de cette réforme
professionnelle c'est celle
d'accompagner les savoirs fondamentaux
que vous avez évoqué et monsieur le
Président de la République ainsi que
maniable la première ministre l'ont
réaffirmé à plusieurs reprises nous
souhaitons préserver les savoirs
fondamentaux nous souhaitons accompagner
ces élèves souvent plus fragiles sur ses
savoirs fondamentaux qui sont essentiels
à leur citoyenneté mais nous souhaitons
également leur donner toutes les cartes
pour qu'ils puissent s'insérer
professionnellement et réussir
l'insertion professionnelle qui
aujourd'hui je tiens à rappeler ne
concerne qu'un élève sur deux diplômés
deux ans après l'obtention de leur
diplôme et or poursuit d'études cette ce
constat-là il n'est évidemment pas le
fait des enseignants qui sont évidemment
pris dans un système c'est de notre
responsabilité collective que
d'accompagner ce changement de système
pour que nous donnions toutes les cartes
aux enseignants pour qu'ils puissent
accompagner les élèves et les mettre en
situation de réussite effective
merci madame la ministre monsieur Cardon
madame la ministre ben écoutez je ne
suis pas surpris de votre réponse vous
confortez même ce que je suis en train
de dire en tout cas tout ce que je vois
c'est que ce gouvernement est un
spécialiste des slogans notre école
faisant là ensemble notre lycée
professionnel faisons ensemble chiche
madame la ministre y aller chez moi en
tout cas il y a les faiseux et les 10
œufs les Français vous demandent tout
simplement d'être les faiseux et de
construire une vraie concertation pour
sauver le lycée professionnel et pas
l'inverse
merci chers collègues la parole et
maintenant un autre collègue philippe
Dominati pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il y a 4 ans
avec Peugeot et Renault la France
disposait de constructeurs automobiles
de dimension mondiale il y a en commun
un actionnaire l'État français qui est
un actionnaire d'influence
depuis l'un à trouver la voie de la
croissance en acceptant d'être dilué
dans le groupe Fiat Chrysler croupitalo
américain et l'autre est passé de la
première place mondiale à celle de plus
petit constructeur automobile européens
hier le directeur général de Renault a
annoncé le troisième volet de son plan
pour cette entreprise ce plan qui
consiste à scinder en deux cette
entreprise et notamment avec de nouveaux
partenaires l'un chinois l'autre
saoudien
dans le même temps le directeur général
de Nissan en début de semaine dans la
presse économique revendiquée la
nécessité de rééquilibrer l'alliance
avec Renault
comme beaucoup de Français je
m'interroge et je m'étonne ce qui semble
être la passivité du gouvernement
français
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires dans la
mesure où
on ne comprend pas pourquoi 4 ans après
la crise suscitée par l'incarcération de
l'ancien directeur général de Renault
d'ailleurs sans preuve provente jusqu'à
ce jour le gouvernement accepte
éventuellement cette remise en cause je
voudrais savoir si il s'agit d'un
rééquilibrage volontaire ou si vous
allez accepter le démantèlement de cette
alliance
merci chers collègues la parole à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie à des finances
et merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Dominati je pense que vous avez
mis le doigt sur la réalité de
l'industrie automobile actuelle jusqu'à
quelques chiffres pour commencer
capitalisation boursière de Renault 6
milliards d'euros
capitalisation boursière de stellantis
44 milliards d'euros Ford 53 milliards
d'euros
Tesla
610 milliards d'euros
deuxième chiffre que je tiens à rappeler
Renault fait 60% de ses ventes c'est la
grande différence par rapport à ces
lentis en Europe l'Europe a décidé
d'abandonner les véhicules thermiques
c'est pour cela que nous pensons que la
stratégie de lucabeo est la bonne
stratégie pour Renault la bonne
stratégie pour cette entreprise c'est
d'abord une stratégie qui va lui
permettre de retrouver de l'espace
financier pour cela qu'elle sépare les
activités thermiques des activités
électriques et qu'elle a besoin d'un
partenaire je partenaire c'est le
chinois jili qui je le rappelle est déjà
actionné en majoritaire de Volvo
actionnaire de lotus et actionnaire de
Daimler en Allemagne c'est donc un
partenaire qui nous paraît un bon
partenaire
sur les activités électriques Renault va
pouvoir donc dégager les moyens
financiers plus importants pour investir
dans le moteur électrique investir dans
le véhicule électrique avec un projet de
1 million de véhicules électriques
réalisés dans le nord de la France
Renaud va donc être un des fers de
l'ange de la réindustrialisation
automobile de notre pays il va
développer également des batteries
électriques pour que nous ayons
l'indépendance totale sur la chaîne il
va développer pour la première fois un
véhicule utilitaire léger électrique qui
va répondre à toutes les questions
comment est souvent posées sur les
artisans les commerçants les BTP les
très petites entreprises qui ont besoin
de véhicules utilitaires électriques
légers ils seront produits à Sandouville
en France par Renault nous shootons donc
cette stratégie qui doit permettre la
réindustrialisation automobile sur la
base du véhicule électrique qui était
lancée par le cademeo et Renault
s'agissant de l'Alliance nous continuons
à penser que cette alliance entre Nissan
et Renaud est pertinente nous soutenons
donc les dispositions qui sont
aujourd'hui sur la table entre Renault
et Nissan car nous a des synergies
possibles qui renforceront encore
Renault
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Dominati
monsieur le ministre je suis pas très
convaincu de votre réponse parce que
vous aurez Nissan ce qu'il y a de gênant
c'est tout sur l'électrique d'un côté le
président de la République nous dit
économiser mettez le chauffage à 19
degrés éteignez la Tour Eiffel faites un
certain nombre de choses la peine à
l'inclusion présidentielle terminée on
offre 7000 euros pour acheter une
voiture par exemple Nissan électrique
dont on ne sait pas véritablement
comment avec nos impôts on pourra
finalement continuer ce développement
avec cette politique dans les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris dans ma ville en 2024
il y aura que des voitures étrangères
pour accueillir nos autres
merci
la parole est désormais à notre collègue
Jean-Michel Arnaud pour le groupe Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs le ministre mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres l'économie et des finances
l'explosion du coup de l'énergie touche
de plein fouet et particuliers les
entreprises mais également les
collectivités territoriales garants des
services publics du quotidien les
communes en particulier ont subi une
hausse stratosphérique des prix lors du
renouvellement de leur contrat de
fournitures d'énergie il en est le même
pour toutes les infrastructures
publiques qui leur sont liées à
commencer par les remontées mécaniques
par exemple au mon département les
Hautes-Alpes pour l'avenir en aide ont
été mis en place ou promis une
succession de dispositifs budgétaires et
financiers tout d'abord cet été dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finance
rectificative a été instauré à notre
initiative le Sénat un filet de sécurité
en faveur des collectivités filer qui
devait originellement concerner 22000
communes que nenni seul une infime
partie des collectivités en seront
finalement bénéficiaires par exemple
dans mon département 5 communes sur 162
ensuite nous avons eu l'introduction
d'un bouclier énergétique dans le projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 que nous
allons bientôt contaminer ici au Sénat
enfin Madame borne première ministre a
récemment annoncé la mise en place d'un
amortisseur électricité nous attendons
là encore la parution d'un décret pour
savoir qui en bénéficiera précisément et
selon quelles conditions monsieur le
ministre tout ceci commence à ressembler
un véritable maquis nous avons du mal à
nous y retrouver alors imaginez
également les maires des petites
communes comment vont s'articuler ces
différents dispositifs toutes les
collectivités seront-elles concernées
par ces mesures de soutien et quand
toucheront-elles les premières aides
c'est essentiel pour le maintien des
services et qu'il manquait du quotidien
qu'elles assument
merci chers collègues
la parole à Monsieur le Ministre
Christophe Béchu une liste de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires merci monsieur le
Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs vous
me permettrez de répondre
puisque la partie collectivité
territoriale a été plus intense dans
votre question que la partie économique
qui s'adressait à Bruno Le Maire d'abord
pour articuler très rapidement hier et
aujourd'hui il y a la situation de
l'année 2022 et il y a la situation de
l'année 2023 sur 2022 les choses sont
assez simples avec le bouclier qui a été
mis en place qui concerne toutes les
collectivités de moins de 10 salariés de
moins de 2 millions d'euros de budget et
pour celle là la règle 2022 sera la
règle 2023 toutes les entités de moins
de 10 salariés c'est le bouclier le
sujet c'est au-dessus pour l'année en
cours et le Sénat il a pris toute sa
part le filet de sécurité qui a été voté
cet été permettait de compenser le fait
que au-delà d'un certain niveau de
dépenses énergétiques il n'y avait pas
de dispositif spécifique pour les
collectivités
à l'heure où nous parlons vous savez que
les collectivités peuvent faire la
demande d'une avance et l'estimation sur
le nombre de communes par département
qui pourrait bénéficier du dispositif
vous avez l'air de le connaître chez
vous je ne le connais pas France entière
pour 2023 bouclier pour les moins de 10
amortisseur pour celles qui sont à plus
de 10 salariés pour faire très simple
quand vous additionnez la moitié de la
facture qui est couverte par la reine et
la part qui est libre au-delà de 180
euros
du kilowatt-heure du mégawatt-heure nous
nous retrouvons dans un dispositif de
soutien qui prend la forme de 50% du
niveau de facture jusqu'à un plafond qui
est situé à 420 euros ça c'est le
dispositif le caractère pas
immédiatement accessible du calcul
explique que le décret est encore à la
minute où nous parlons en cours de
rédaction et vous mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs vous allez dans quelques
jours pouvoir prendre le filet de
sécurité qui arrive de l'Assemblée avec
un aval qui a été donné par le
gouvernement pour un dispositif qui est
beaucoup plus puissant que celui qui a
été validé pour l'année 20002 puisque
c'est un milliard et demi d'euros que
nous envisageons de consacrer au soutien
des factures énergétiques de toutes les
collectivités locales qui se retrouvent
avec une diminution de leur capacité
d'autofinancement trop importante pour
qu'elle puisse supporter seul la facture
que le ministre
d'amélioration et nous ne doutons pas
que le dialogue permettra de simplifier
le dispositif
je suis Arnaud
peut-être monsieur le ministre parce que
vous n'avez pas pu terminer votre
intervention je n'ai pas tout compris
dans la réponse mais je tiens à vous
dire de manière très précise à titre
d'illustration dans mon département
lorsque vous regardez le dispositif
d'amortisseur électricité lorsque par
exemple les stations de sports d'hiver
des Hautes-Alpes se retrouvent à
utiliser ce dispositif elle se retrouve
avec une capacité à assumer les charges
énergétiques à hauteur de 20% de leur
chiffre d'affaires et donc cela signifie
que elles sont en situation de risque
vital à l'issue de la saison elles sont
en situation de faillite donc je crois
qu'il est nécessaire dans le dialogue
parlementaire de trouver des solutions
mais il faut trouver des solutions
opérationnelles et dès le 1er décembre
monsieur le ministre je vous en conjure
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Claudine
Thomas pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre en août dernier
lors du vote de la loi de finances
rectificative pour 2022 le groupe les
républicains a fait adopter un
amendement il visait à mettre en place
les premiers crédits permettant de
lancer dès l'automne suivant le chantier
de la mise en œuvre d'une carte Vitale
biométrique permettant de s'assurer
s'assurer de l'identité de son détenteur
la vie du gouvernement était à l'époque
un avis de sagesse et vous vous étiez
engagé à prévoir d'autres crédits dans
le plfs plff pardon 2023 l'enjeu est
important
un rapport conjoint de lié l'IGF et de
Ligas à estimé que le nombre de
titulaires d'une carte Vitale excédé de
plus de 7 millions le nombre de
personnes résidant en France
un rapport c'est un rapport sénatorial
quant à lui l'évaluait en 2019 entre
deux et plus de 5 millions et la
directrice de la sécurité sociale en
2020 reconnaît celle lors d'une audition
Parlement un surnom de 2,16 millions de
cartes vitales quant au montant de la
fraude sociale il est aussi ré entre 14
et 45 milliards d'euros par an la fraude
à la carte Vitale ayant toute sa part
dans cette dérive
madame ce sujet de la fraude sociale
mériterait que le gouvernement s'en
saisisse vraiment
or que constate-t-on non seulement le
gouvernement n'a rien fait pour aller
dans ce sens mais pire encore aucun
crédit n'est inscrit pour cette action
au PLFSS 2023
décidément votre gouvernement a bien du
mal à écouter le Parlement apprendre le
chemin de la réforme et à se donner les
moyens et d'économiser l'argent public
j'aurais donc trois questions
ne pensez-vous pas madame la Première
ministre que la lutte contre la fraude
sociale devrait être une priorité et que
tous les moyens pour y contribuer de
votre être mise en oeuvre pourquoi
avez-vous refusé d'inscrire pour 2023
des crédits et donc d'engager enfin le
programme de création des cartes vitales
biométriques et pour finir au-delà de
votre réticence à agir se poser une
question plus large que ne pensez-vous
pas que dans une démocratie les
décisions du Parlement pardon
c'est-à-dire ce que prévoit la loi doit
être respectée par le gouvernement
la parole pour répondre est à Madame
Agnès firmant le Bodo ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Claudine Thomas vous
l'avez dit la lutte contre la fraude est
un sujet essentiel à la fois pour des
raisons éthiques et de soutenabilité de
notre modèle de protection sociale c'est
bien parce que c'est un sujet essentiel
que dans ce PLFSS 2023 que nous avons
commencé à examiner au Sénat mon
collègue Gabriel Attal et moi-même
portant des mesures fortes et
ambitieuses à la fois pour prévenir
détecter et sanctionner les fraudes
conformément aux engagements qui ont été
pris lors du vote au Parlement en
juillet dernier une mission
IgA IGF a été lancé en vue d'évaluer
l'intérêt et les conditions de mise en
oeuvre d'une carte Vitale biométrique
cette mission permettra de recenser des
travaux déjà conduits pour évaluer la
fraude à l'usage des cartes et notamment
son impact financier elle analysera
ensuite les différentes solutions
techniques et leur faisabilité et le cas
échéant leurs conditions de mise en
oeuvre dans le même temps le
gouvernement a lancé le chantier d'une
carte Vitale dématérialisée qui
correspondent davantage aux nouveaux
usages ainsi qu'aux attentes des
professionnels de santé eux-mêmes une
phase d'expérimentation a été entamée en
2019 auprès d'assurer et des
professionnels de santé la carte vitale
des matérialisée est en cours dans huit
départements jusqu'à l'année jusqu'à la
fin de l'année auprès des assurés
volontaires en parallèle de cette étude
sur la carte Vitale biométrique le
gouvernement entend aller au terme de
cette expérimentation qui d'ailleurs
pour sécuriser l'identification de la
personne contient de la biométrie cette
carte vitale des matérialisée pourrait
être généralisée à partir de 2023 en
fonction de résultat de l'évaluation et
des exigences de simplification
auxquelles nous sommes très attachés je
vous remercie
bien merci Madame la Ministre la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue Marie
Harley de Carlotti pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues depuis 54
jours le sang coule en Iran et c'est
d'abord le sang des femmes en février 79
avant même l'instauration de la
République islamique d'Iran l'ayatollah
romini considérait déjà que la liberté
de la femme était un principal obstacle
à son projet politique et depuis
l'élection de l'ultra conservateur Haïti
la situation c'est encore dégradée
depuis 54 jours depuis la mort de Massa
Amini les manifestations se multiplient
et la répression est de plus en plus
brutale au fur et à mesure que le
pouvoir se sent en danger une répression
sans précédent s'en bat sur le peuple
iranien la politique ouvre la police
ouvre le feu sur les manifestants il y a
plus de 300 morts 14000 arrestations
comme ces deux journalistes qui sont
aujourd'hui en prison parce qu'elles ont
dénoncé le crime commis par la police
des mœurs toutes celles qui brûlent leur
voile qui arragent leur carcans qui se
coupe les cheveux risque aujourd'hui la
peine de mort
l'intégralité des droits humains et
pourtant et pourtant depuis mai 2021 la
République islamique d'Iran est membre
de la Commission de la condition des
femmes des Nations Unies c'est
surréaliste en niant le droit des femmes
et emmenant une répression féroce contre
son peuple l'Iran vous en conviendrez à
démontrer qu'il n'avait pas sa place au
sein d'une commission qui promeut le
droit des femmes et l'égalité des sexes
les premiers à réagir ont été les
Canadiens puis ce furent les États-Unis
qui lancent désormais une initiative
pour provoquer le départ de l'Iran de
cet instance que dit la France que dit
la France monsieur le ministre vous
allez allez-vous exiger l'exclusion de
l'Iran de la Commission des Droits des
Femmes de l'ONU le régime des mots là
n'a rien à y faire
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier belge
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Carlotti d'abord je voudrais
excuser l'absence de la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Madame Catherine Colonna
oui le mouvement de protestation des
iraniennes et des Iraniens se poursuit
alors que le 26 octobre a marqué le 40e
jour suivant le décès de Massa Amini qui
a un moment essentiel du
cyclable de deuil musulman chiite
plusieurs cérémonies de deuil pour
d'autres protestataires décédés au début
du mouvement ont été organisés ces
derniers jours c'est très nombreux et
triste anniversaire suicide et
rassemblements qui continuent de faire
résonner qui a le cri femme vit liberté
face au revendication légitime de la
jeunesse iranienne les autorités
maintiennent leur répression violente et
oui le bilan aujourd'hui est de plus de
300 morts comme vous le savez nous avons
réagi fermement à cette brutalité
notamment à travers un premier paquet de
sanctions européennes adopté le 17
octobre visant les responsables de la
répression nous travaillons actuellement
avec nos partenaires européens à un
second paquet de sanctions visant
d'autres respons il ne doit y avoir et
il n'y aura aucune impunité à aucun
niveau en fin de semaine dernière nous
avons également échangé avec nos
partenaires du G7 au sein de l'évolution
de la situation en Iran nous partageons
les mêmes préoccupations très fortes
quant à la réponse brutale des autorités
iraniennes aux aspirations légitimes de
sa population nous sommes donc tous au
clair si la répression se poursuit c'est
aussi les sanctions qui se poursuivront
et la France agira à tous les niveaux y
compris au niveau de l'organisation des
Nations Unies si nécessaire
madame Carlotti
merci monsieur le ministre je regrette
cette réponse timide
certes nous certes des sanctions ont été
prises par la France et par l'Union
européenne mais elles sont bien timides
aujourd'hui et pendant ce temps-là le
régime continue à tuer aujourd'hui la
situation c'est aggravée il y a urgence
et c'est plus le moment de la simple
compassion ça ne suffit pas nous
attendons de la France qu'elle soit plus
audible pour dénoncer la répression et
pour défendre ceux qui se battent pour
leur liberté alors faisons les sortir de
la Commission
[Applaudissements]
bien merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Jérôme
Bacher pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues nous
pouvons penser que en fin d'année nous
serons à 200 milliards de déficit
commercial 150 milliards sur trois
trimestres et il s'aggravent de
trimestre entre trimestre alors Monsieur
le Ministre comment analysez-vous votre
échec et qu'elle à partir de cette bonne
analyse quelle piste avez-vous pour
redresser la barre
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
je suis le sénateur pas cher si c'est un
échec c'est un échec collectif puisque
depuis 2000 la balance commerciale n'a
jamais été excédentaire dans notre pays
donc je suggère je vous suggère de
chercher plutôt ensemble des solutions
plutôt que d'akablé tous les bancs de
cette assemblée gauche et droite
confondues la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui l'excédent commercial dont
j'ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises que
nous devions en faire une des grandes
batailles économiques de la prochaine
décennie c'est d'abord dû à
l'augmentation de la facture énergétique
et à notre dépendance énergétique sur
les 16 milliards d'euros de déficits
commerciales supplémentaires que nous
venons d'enregistrer les deux tiers sont
liés à la facture énergétique je cherche
pas je ne cherche pas des subterfuges je
dis qu'elles sont les réalités
aujourd'hui des chiffres la deuxième
raison vous la connaissez aussi bien que
moi je connais votre attachement à ce
sujet
c'est la désindustrialisation massive de
la France depuis trois décennies il n'y
aura pas d'excédent de la balance
commerciale française sans
réindustrialisation massive rapide
volontariste notre pays quelle est la
seule majorité qui depuis 20 ans
a recréer des emplois industriels dans
notre pays c'est la nôtre
quelle est la seule majorité qui peut
dire que nous avons ouvert plus d'usines
l'année dernière que nous en avons fermé
c'est la nôtre
quelle est la seule majorité qui est le
courage de baisser les impôts de
production de 10 milliards d'euros et
qui va à nouveau les baisser pour les
années qui viennent c'est la nôtre donc
si vous voulez réduire le déficit de la
balance commerciale extérieure votez
avec nous la nouvelle baisse des impôts
de production soutenez l'industrie
soutenez leur industrialisation du pays
et là nous aurons enfin une balance
commerciale extérieure positive
[Applaudissements]
monsieur bachel alors Monsieur le
Ministre tout à l'heure vous allez
raconter une histoire là vous nous a
raconté des histoires
car nous venons exactement de vous
expliquer ce qu'il fallait faire écoutez
bien la suite des questions du groupe
les républicains tout à l'heure on vous
a expliqué ce que c'était pour le
déficit public avec Priscille Lavarde
sur la réindustrialisation de notre
industrie de santé sur la
réindustrialisation notre automobile la
semaine dernière où il y a 15 jours plus
exactement le rendu plomb vous rappelait
sur l'agriculture oui nous vous faisons
des propositions mais vous les entendez
pas par dogme nous proposons d'abord
d'énormes et après on dit à notre
industrie vous n'avez plus qu'à vous
adapter et bien non on donne des Caps
clairs monsieur le ministre on indique
ce qu'on veut faire au pays vous nous
dites il faut que ça soit la prochaine
décennie mais vous avez raté la décennie
dernière vous avez raté la décennie
dernière ce pays né aujourd'hui pas
souverain et en ce jour anniversaire de
la mort du général la souveraineté
aurait méritée d'être vraiment mise à
l'honneur vous l'avez la souveraineté
dans les titres vous ne l'avez pas dans
les fêtes
[Applaudissements]
la parole la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Claude Kern pour le
groupe Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'installation illicite des
gens du voyage est une problématique qui
n'est pas nouvelle loin de là cela fait
20 ans qu'elle revient régulièrement sur
le tapis sans toutefois constater de
changement effectifs la loi Besson n'est
ni efficace ni appliquée et des
situations difficiles en découlent pour
leur pour nos communes j'ai encore eu
connaissance de plusieurs cas en Alsace
et je sais que mes collègues élus dans
d'autres départements sont confrontés
aux mêmes problématiques certes
certaines intercommunalités encore des
difficultés pour développer des airs du
grand passage nécessaire au respect de
la loi mais qu'en est-il des territoires
qui sont en conformité avec le schéma
départemental et qui subissent
régulièrement des installations
illicites ces communautés refusant de
s'installer sur les airs dédiées les
élus se retrouvent alors démunies face à
des communautés qui ont une parfaite
connaissance des procédures leur
permettant de faire échec à n'arrêter
préfectoral de mise en demeure en
saisissant immédiatement le juge
administratif d'un référé suspensif un
trou dans la raquette qui leur permet de
prolonger leur présence sur le site
qu'ils ont investi en toute illégalité
c'est cette suspension qui pose problème
que compte faire le gouvernement pour
faire respecter la loi sans pour autant
oublier la question de l'après qui est
tout aussi importante car trop souvent
les terrains occupés sont laissés dans
un mauvais état avec des dégâts
conséquents monsieur le ministre dans
quel débat délai allez-vous déposer un
projet de loi qui met définitivement un
terme à ces installations illicites et
protège les élus
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les stateurs monsieur le
sénateur Kern comme vous je constate que
les lois Besson 1 et Besson 2 sont
difficilement applicables et en effet je
crois que l'autorité républicaine est
plusieurs fois bafouée les accueils ont
mis en place par les élus locaux souvent
ravagés et évidemment pour nos citoyens
des décisions administratives ou
d'édition de justice peut compréhensible
et qu'à ce titre je veux évidemment
faire le constat avec vous que nous
devons améliorer le texte de loi vous
m'accorderez que les préfets de la
République appliquent la loi telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui rédigée faut-il
que ce soit une proposition de loi après
tout la Haute Assemblée comme
l'Assemblée nationale pourrait tout à
fait le proposer faut-il que ce soit un
texte du Gouvernement peut-être un texte
ensemble si vous le permettez monsieur
le sénateur pour pouvoir à la fois
évidemment accueillir les gens du voyage
qui ont évidemment le droit de vivre
comme il le souhaite sur le territoire
de la République évidemment au
conformité
vous savez que la bien-séance
républicaine et le respect évidemment
des choses publiques ainsi que la
propriété privée de nos concitoyens pour
avoir été maire d'une commune qui
n'avait pas d'un accueil des gens du
voyage je sais à quel point il est
difficile pour une mairie de pouvoir la
mettre en place mais je veux rappeler
d'abord que la loi Besson 2 doit
répondre pour l'ensemble des élus de la
République au schéma départementaux et
je ne peux malheureusement que constater
qu'à certains nombre de conseils
départementaux n'ont pas mis en place en
place encore leur schéma départemental
où on passe demander la révision de
celui-ci deuxièmement la question qui se
pose monsieur le sénateur c'est lorsque
les personnes s'installent sur des
terrains privés ou sur un terrain public
ou une partie d'un terrain public ou le
détenteur de la propriété ne souhaite
pas déposer plainte soit pour des
raisons volontaires soit parce qu'on ne
connaît pas le propriétaire de ce
terrain voilà notamment avide juridique
auquel il faudra tous répondre pour que
les préfets puissent appliquer la force
publique lorsqu'ils ont soit en flag
soit par décision de justice les moyens
de le faire et ils le font à chaque fois
que vous me saisissez
merci Monsieur Kern
merci monsieur le ministre je nous
prenons note de votre proposition et
nous sommes naturellement prêts à
travailler avec vous pour améliorer ces
situations mais comprenez que
aujourd'hui c'est si ces installations
illicites ne peuvent plus perdus
perdurer et d'autant plus qu'elles ont
souvent lieu à proximité d'habitation
privée
un dernier mot concernant peut-être
également l'installation illégale de
cirque qui s'installe malgré
l'interdiction formelle qui leur est
notifié préalablement sur ce point
également les élus locaux sont en
attente d'une réponse rapide et
efficiente merci merci chers collègues
nous en avons terminé pour aujourd'hui
je vous rappelle que les prochaines
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
auront lieu le mercredi 16 novembre 2022
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30
pour la suite du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]